this is Batman this is Superman
you know them because you love comics
well this is Ghost World
I'm April and David boring and their
comics too and their creator is really
important so pay attention because
you're about to watch a really great
story about one of the most influential
people in the world of comics oh and is
narrated by would Harry four six eight
twelve fifteen okay
this is the cover of the 2010 graphic
novel Wilson I started the endearingly
can cankerous main character and story
was adapted into a movie
Wilson's author is Daniel Clowes Dan as
many things his work would go on to
change the trajectory of comics in
popular culture as we know it
[Music]
dan was born in Chicago on April 14th
1961 coming of age in the 1970s dan
Spanish formative years surrounded by
his hippie classmates but while they
were listening to the Grateful Dead and
Jefferson Airplane and was dedicating
himself to different pursuits to be into
comics when I was in high school was
like the lowest thing he could possibly
be into I mean I can't think of anything
that would have been more pathetic
he felt like an outsider like you truly
laid claim to it in a way no one else
did drawing was his outlet dan graduated
from high school in 1979 into camping to
New York City to attend art school his
very first published comic was arguably
a disaster the sails got low enough
where the publisher said you know I
think we're just gonna we're gonna
cancel this comment I felt like okay
though I had my shot that's it it would
be a second comic that would change
Dan's career it was 1989 dan released
eight ball collection of comics of
varying genres links and drawing styles
readers loved it no one had ever seen a
comic told like this you know I was
doing the kind of comics I always wanted
to read and I thought there's got to be
other people like me and it turned out
that I wasn't such a you know strange
person after all
that's me
for her and that's a clip from a movie
adaptation of this world as this tale of
teenage doldrums made its way from
comment to film it became the work that
brought Dan's name recognition to the
level of a cult celebrity I felt like I
had sort of gone to a different level
where people took me more seriously you
know it was more than just the guy
address comics beyond what it did for
Dan those world helped to change the
perception of graphic novels and comics
as a whole publishers were struggling
and all of a sudden people were doing
graphic novels and some of these are
actually selling and so it just became
this time for graphic novels
[Music]
post ghost world things got busy his
work has been translated into over 20
languages his writing would gone to be
adapted in two more movies Art School
Confidential and the aforementioned
Wilson and what helped make all this
possible and what made Dan so beloved
among so many people are his characters
whenever I read somebody talked about
all his characters are sad losers
anything really are they you know I've
always felt that the your goal when
you're doing a story of real characters
is that you have to find a way to love
them no matter who they are with proper
social pact forever eluding them they
are endearing Outsiders just as dan once
was I don't know what you know what's
gonna what the future will hold it all I
never think about that stuff I just hope
I can you know keep you know scribbling
away for a few more years till the
Alzheimer's kicks in
[Music]
you